KARIM LAKHANI: Open innovation and
crowdsourcing is all around you.
When you read an article in Wikipedia,
hundreds if not thousands of people
have contributed to that article.
When you use your smartphone, whether
that be an Apple device or an Android
device, the underlying software has
been developed by hundreds of thousands
of people working collectively
to create that software
and not working for these
companies like Apple or Google.
When you use your computer,
and you use the internet,
the underlying infrastructure
of the internet
has been developed
through open innovation.
One of the most valuable
companies in the world, Apple,
thinks about open source and open
innovation as key to their success.
Indeed, the top companies
around the world
have figured out how to use the wisdom
of the crowd, the wisdom of people
distributed around the world, to help
them create products and services
that we use on a daily basis.